hmm asked us just stayed home getting up
on a government not conspiracy but like
what kind of like this one had me not
the the premise isn't funny but like
what follows this funny so apparently
and someone can correct me on this but
apparently the government was trying to
fund a health care type division kind of
like DARPA yeah DARPA like the military
contractor or whatever
I think they've built like I don't know
kind of like Boston Dynamics type [ __ ]
okay
could be wrong whatever so I was reading
about something called like harpa which
is like basically with what the
government was supposedly trying to do
was they're trying to date a mine
consumer devices to prevent mass
tragedies okay and they specifically
mentioned a Fitbit so like data mining a
Fitbit to predict when someone was about
to commit a tragedy I don't [ __ ] you a
dude takes a salsa class and the [ __ ]
FBI rate occurs you know what I'm saying
like you imagine how [ __ ] bad that
would be there's no way I feel you could
connect a Fitbit well you can heart rate
well no it's not about the one it's
about like patterns I mean I guess like
I guess I think it's about like
Association and like going one thing
like I guess my problem is correlation I
guess yeah but what what data can get
from a Fitbit because in my mind Fitbit
doesn't offer like GPS or does it like I
thought Fitbit just monitors like your
heart rate and general health I think it
does a bunch of [ __ ] but like steps and
I think it does GPS does it okay but
maybe then that then that's why I'm
wrong I was just imagining like this
things are just strictly going off like
heart rate oh yeah dude's got explain
something really weird in court
that's what we doing on July 17th I went
to the grocery store honey price I think
in a salsa class I see a salsa class I
put the Fitbit on my dick
what
I'm put it but I got my little do we
whoa
agreement why I know I wanted to see my
wife thought that it would be without
one put it on the deck in heat we
thought like a [ __ ] right it would stay
up we thought her stay up yeah so he put
it on his put it on the decks wanted to
track that for us to put it on the deck
and put on this day put on the deck okay
no further questions your honor
is the whole line of people so did
everyone yeah we all put it on our death
you all put it on our date okay well
everybody put on their dick I guess fitb
it must have been like one of the
devices it was like a whole bunch of
data mining and they yeah yeah they know
was analyzed all the data together and
figure out trends and and but I don't
know and I [ __ ] know I know
that's fascinating no it's kind of
interesting yeah I mean I know I don't
think Apple devices were part of it
Apple doesn't partner with the
government or whoever I was good to know
that Fitbit does though yeah great to
know that good to know that yeah that's
cool yeah I'll be buying tons of their
products now you know what else is
really cool what is Amazon working with
local police departments for the for the
ring camera they're now offering that
information to to certain like law
enforcement mm-hmm like they can just as
far as I read they can just like tap
into a feed huh
with like a proper warrant or whatever
that's sick that's that's really cool
there's no that's really cool yeah oh
that's super sick yeah so next time I'm
stealing furniture
yeah and bringing it back to my place
hmm I'll keep that in mind yeah yeah I'm
just thinking like that's probably good
for the vast majority of people who I
mean like big brothers [ __ ] I think
that's like a slippery slope thing yeah
but you don't think they can [ __ ] tap
into every security camera on every
single building around I mean everything
yeah but that's like that's not like the
same thing sort of I think a consumer
device you know what I'm saying that you
buy for your own purpose and then like
all this
the government can use that that's a
little weird yeah but yeah that's true I
don't hear what do you guys think no we
think it's kind of [ __ ] up too how do
you guys do the pseudo facetiming the
FBI well in certain cases we find yeah
okay alright hold on oh yeah David's got
some points here yeah yeah I don't know
but yeah I thought that was really sick
yeah really cool yeah really cool that
Amazon's doing that taking it upon
themselves to build a mass viewing
network
I'm just local PD I'm just thinking of
like some dude you know there's some
like couple getting divorced because
like someone committed adultery or
someone like that mm-hmm and like during
the hearing session one of them pulls up
a video feed from the ring of him
bringing like [ __ ] six girls back
he's a vice versa
yoga electrician electricians it was a
[ __ ] was I thinking yeah it's me yeah
and I put the Fitbit on my dick what
else do you want to know related yeah
yeah and I put the Fitbit on my dick the
paramedic oh we weren't but okay um I
just I'm getting it and getting things
off my chest right now I put the paper
on my dick did you put anywhere else
from put it the butter but mass okay
okay all right
but the minimize and the acid in the
dick so back to the ring light I just
wanna go to someone's ring light and
just like just hang out yeah
just chill yeah just not creepy just
like
pull-up plus cigarette just dude ring it
was good fun what the [ __ ] is up full
how you doing yeah I was just in the
neighborhood man I said come through say
what's up passing by I saw the ring
thought I'd say what's good because you
know you can talk bad yeah
that's so funny but that's a [ __ ] milk
you think right there yeah that's
innocent yeah hey dude how you doing oh
you got a nice house yeah just wanted to
say what's up beautiful house oh I I
don't want to come in I'm just yeah and
just come out here admiring just want to
say what's good what do you do yeah I'm
at work right now
cool sweet man what do you do what do
you do what do you do for work I can't I
can't really talk come on me you could
tell me what you do I'm a data analyst
sick is sick where'd you go to school I
can't come on come on you never hang
with the boys anymore like five dude you
can own this porch huh come back crack
home with us brother won't be here yeah
nice fun pork you guys have to go I'm
gonna call the police don't be a narc
dude come on okay I don't wanna get
pinched snitch dude snitch
I didn't realize this was a [ __ ]
snitch ring all lame-o's own it out of
here
those those videos on whenever I see us
on Twitter or whatever those scare me
the most who are videos from rings or
whatever that in really creepy [ __ ]
happens you know oh yeah someone a mask
runs up and just like runs away and
you're like what the [ __ ]
or like ghosts and [ __ ] you're like an
alien walks up and clicks a button and
then walks away and it was like last
night and it's always something like
stupid Midwest town in the middle of
nowhere an alien walked up to the thing
and then walked away no one knows why
that's scary man and definitely real I
want to do do the mask face safe now I'm
gonna run down a block like a [ __ ]
madman and run away just looks at that
in the morning like that's [ __ ]
creepy it is dude it's it's it's kind of
funny though dude just does that on his
way to Taco Bell because he gets a
[ __ ] cheesy gordita crunch just
exists so funny yeah
makes the [ __ ] out of like 12 days or
you can really freak people out you
could just leave you could walk up and
just leave like a little plant it just
yeah thing walk away yeah just things
creepy yeah super creepy yeah they're
just not like something more slightly
ominous yeah just like it's like a PVC
pipe
it's creepy look at the camera walk away
yeah this is a pretty way
[Music]